minor hockey is back
you guys ready yep
all right you play hard
the greater toronto hockey league hit
the ice this month for the first time
since december after ontario eased
pandemic restrictions cameron's look
there he is yeah you can wave now number
four
capacity is limited the arena is half
empty
but to danielle cameron it's half full
[Music]
yay
the hockey mom cheering on
seven-year-old cameron her oldest of
three children in one of three games he
and his sister are playing this saturday
that's hard work
danielle's husband aaron is better known
as coach during the pandemic any chance
that some normalcy
is welcoming and for the kids especially
i mean they've lost so much
through the pandemic and
you know doubly with me
going through what i'm going through
with cancer
[Applause]
yay for danielle cheering from the
stands is a high-risk activity
in december 2019 she was diagnosed with
inflammatory breast cancer a rare
particularly deadly disease penelope
come come see mama
she now requires in-hospital treatment
every three weeks but for now at least
her stage four cancer is stable people
like to think of stage four as
as your cancer sleeping like that's what
i tell my kids they ask me all the time
mommy is your cancer still there and
i'll say well
yes but it's sleeping right now
she remains immunocompromised and highly
vulnerable to covet 19. during the
pandemic she stayed mostly indoors the
family canceled a planned vacation to
the dominican republic and where's daddy
can you see
but after two years danielle is done
hiding at home i'm tired of waiting i
don't know how much time i have
on this earth and hopefully it's many
many years to come but if it's not i
don't want to wait
to go and see my friends or to make
memories with my children and every time
they tell me to get a booster i'll get a
booster and we're going to live our
lives but safely
learning to live with covet 19 has
become something of a controversial
catchphrase used by politicians we have
to learn to live with it learn to live
with the virus learning to live with
covid business owners life has to go on
at this point and protesters
but now even frontline staff here in
danielle's hospital are talking about
the need to find a new way forward
learning to live with it is what we as a
health care community needs to be
prepared to do dr leon rivlin is the
medical director and chief of the
emergency department at toronto's humber
river hospital who's your surgeon he and
his team measure the pandemic both by
the numbers and by who comes through
that door every day
on this morning there's a patient with a
gunshot wound another from a car
accident
and this woman with covet 19
struggling to breathe
your heart rate is still faster than i
want it to be her doctor tazly ninja is
the physician in charge of the
hospital's pandemic response she's a
middle aged woman with no medical
history otherwise healthy
here her risk factor really was that she
was not vaccinated
but these days their most pressing
concern isn't covid19 per se
you have 14 patients but rather the fall
from two years of pandemic lockdowns
including a sharp spike in the number of
patients suffering mental and emotional
distress don't give me food we want to
help you
this patient was brought to emergency by
police okay what's the story arrested
for threatening behavior outside a
nearby shopping plaza opens up his shirt
i guess and says i've got a bomb i'm
going to pull this place up dr rivlin
says the man has a history of substance
abuse and psychosis
i get it i do not like human beings
the patient is eventually given
medication and transferred to the
hospital's mental health department the
volume
of the number of cases that are
presenting with this level of agitation
has increased substantially
moments later another man is admitted
with a history of depression and
substance abuse hey there i'm dr rivlin
police say he threatened to kill his
father he just don't like me he just
don't he just hates me the pandemic
creates this general sense of anxiety
then when you add pre-existing disease
whether it's psychosis or depression
then it only amplifies it have you ever
injured your dad have you ever heard him
in the past never
okay so that's what we're seeing a lot
of here we're seeing new cases and we're
seeing recurrence of old cases what's
driving this do you think because
obviously we know it's sort of lockdown
related i assume right yes andrew
kabaluna is a nurse who specializes in
mental health and addictions
he says the pandemic's fifth wave has
been the worst more cases of depression
more anxiety
more alcohol use more addiction problems
so it's just been severe all around
and more patients arriving in the er
with advanced illness who are delayed in
receiving treatment because their family
doctor's office is closed access to care
is definitely limited when when your
doctor's offices are less available to
see the pain that you have today that
you came in with
is not related to your heart from what i
can see i think it's shoulder pain we
decrease the disease burden of covid in
the community but we increase the
disease burden of other regular diseases
which aren't managed the main goal of
the pandemic restrictions he notes is to
reduce the burden on hospitals and
intensive care units in particular but
in this icu the covid19 caseload is now
manageable according to critical care
specialist dr jamie spiegelman we're
really only seeing critical illness in
two types of patients
them being the unvaccinated patients and
the immunocompromised patients data from
the uk suggests the chances of a fully
vaccinated person dying from omicron are
now comparable to the seasonal flu
though covid19 remains far more
transmissible but what if we see a new
variant another wave and
hospitalizations rise once again covet
is always going to be there this year we
had omicron last year we had delta what
is it going to be next year and how are
we going to respond to it i'm just going
to give this to the nurse and then we'll
carry on we need to have a broader
strategic plan that's a bit more than
the reactive plan that we currently have
the harm caused by two years of pandemic
restrictions is plain to see but the
challenge facing public health moving
forward is how to avoid another lockdown
while also protecting the most
vulnerable in other words what does
learning to live with covid19 look like
to those who can die from it
has barely left her apartment in two
years i only go out
when i need to come to the hospital you
know she has stage four breast cancer
which has spread to her lungs
rootman is fully vaccinated against
covid19
but an infection would still be
dangerous according to her oncologist dr
gotham sudan i think with any cancer
patient who's on chemotherapy like their
immune system is not strong enough to
tolerate kovid
he says the fifth wave has witnessed an
explosion of cancer patients with
omicron which causes further
complications and delays for their
treatment how are you and i've had a few
patients who have passed away from kobe
2 are quite healthy and doing well on
treatment and for dr sudan that risk hi
mom it's close to home you're here
where's his shirt then i was like very
short very short
in 2017 his mother was diagnosed with
cancer
they live in the same house and when the
pandemic hit they kept their distance i
stayed one and a half year inside the
house it was difficult
like i could not go anywhere you asked
your teeth it's going to take a while
today she's fully vaccinated against
covid19 and cancer-free
though still receiving chemotherapy
which weakens her immune system i want
him to get married soon
he should be
she says she'll continue wearing a mask
and avoiding crowds indefinitely she's
planning to skip a family wedding next
month i do go out now
but i haven't been very careful
not like
before and i'm scared to i don't want to
end up in the hospital that's what
scares me
if i end up in auto i won't be
coming back we should go back to greece
for sure we will go we're for sure we're
good to go still both she and her son
support removing pandemic restrictions
so long as our hospitals can cope
the new reality is that kovit is here to
stay i want restrictions to
you know cut down i want there to be
more normalcy but it does really it's
proportional to our icu capacity
if we don't have beds to treat critical
ill patients you can't take the
restrictions down because then we have
to choose between who gets cpr and
intubated and who doesn't and that
really is critical care that we need to
conserve how are you feeling
don't you i gotta have them take the
tube out okay because i don't think we
need it just be mindful of all the
people who are not as healthy as you and
you don't know who is immunocompromised
and who not and so do your part and get
vaccinated hanging on the wall in his
office this card that says thank you for
helping my mummy
all right was that fun penelope we have
fun hockey games given to dr sudan by
cameron and his sister sierra
last christmas the hockey mom and her
children caught covid19 there we go good
job you guys did a great job today
danielle says it was scary it was awful
but we survived we took precautions we
did all the things we were told we were
supposed to do and we got over it
and hopefully we never have to get it
again
good job and the family vacation to the
dominican republic they had to cancel a
couple of years ago
they've just rebooked for next month
it's been two years of being on edge and
not knowing what to expect and being
scared and fear-mongering people need to
just enjoy their lives like life is
short pandemic or no pandemic we still
have to make memories and enjoy our life
we just have to be smart about it
and be safe